desde 2017 no había contactos directos
entre un primer ministro israelí y el
presidente de la autoridad palestina
cinco años después de yair lapid y
mahmud abás mantuvieron una conversación
telefónica en vísperas de la visita del
presidente estadounidense de joe biden a
medio oriente la próxima semana
trascendieron en pocos detalles de la
conversación según la oficina del
premier israelí la pide le envió sus
mejores deseos a bases de cara a la
festividad musulmana de eid al-adha y
ambos acordaron continuar con la
cooperación y mantener la calma este fue
el último de tres contactos de a baxe
con líderes israelíes previamente el
viernes por la mañana diálogo también
por teléfono con el presidente israelí
isaac herzog mientras que el jueves por
la tarde recibió en ramala al ministro
de defensa benny gantz el objetivo es
llevar a la tranquilidad de cara a la
visita de biden que se ve ensombrecida
entre otros hechos por el asesinato de
la periodista palestino estadounidense
de sin agua que el 11 de mayo pasado en
jenín precisamente esta semana y tras un
estudio forense inconcluso de la bala
washington señaló que probablemente las
fuerzas israelíes
a la reportera de manera no intencional
una conclusión que generó malestar en
ambos lados más allá de estos contactos
no se espera que esto avance mucho más
el martes en una visita fugaz a parís el
lápiz dijo que no tiene en sus planes en
negociaciones con abbas aunque a
diferencia de su predecesor en naftalí
bennett no descarta esa posibilidad por
su parte abbas es una figura algo
debilitada entre los palestinos frente
al avance del grupo islamista hamás a
todo esto se suma la desconfianza entre
ambos lados que hace casi imposible que
haya negociaciones serias de pasa para
poner fin a un conflicto de décadas
entre israelíes y palestinos